un empleado del zoológico publicó el
siguiente diagrama de tallo y hoja que
muestra el número de tortugas en cada
uno de los zoológicos más importantes
del país recuerda que los diagramas de
tallo y hoja lo que nos hacen es darnos
en esta primera columna digamos que las
decenas es decir cero decenas cuatro
unidades cero decenas cuatro unidades
será decenas ocho unidades o aquí tres
decenas más dos unidades tres decenas
más siete o cinco decenas más dos este
dos realmente no representados sino 52
dado que está en la fila del 5 la
pregunta aquí es cuál fue el mayor
número de tortugas en cualquier
zoológico dado lo que explicaba la
columna de las decenas nos dirá que aquí
tenemos de 10 a 19 de 20 a 29 30 39 y
así en este caso la decena más grande
será de 50 y la unidad más grande de 252
este es el número mayor de tortugas que
hay en cualquier zoológico los demás
estarán en 40
43 44 o 23 28 4 19 entendemos la lógica
52 este fue el número más grande que
tuvimos de tortugas vamos a escribirlo
y comprobemos la respuesta
vamos a hacer uno más un estadístico de
una cadena de supermercados creó el
siguiente diagrama de tallo y hoja que
muestra el número de granadas en cada
una de las tiendas volvemos a tener
nuestra columna de las decenas así como
las unidades recuerda este 0 representa
40 en algunas de las tiendas hubo 40 40
10 no significa un 0 significa la decena
con su unidad 10 vamos a ver cuál es la
pregunta cuál fue el menor número de
granadas en cualquier tienda de
comestibles ahora nos iremos hacia el
número más pequeño en este caso nos
iremos hacia la escena más pequeña
que en este caso de los ceros no tuvimos
ninguna incidencia mientras que en el de
las decenas tuvimos diez o trece cuál es
más pequeño pues 10 el número menor de
granadas en cualquier tienda fue de 10
estamos en la fila que va de 10 a 19
y el número de unidad más pequeño fue 0
tenemos 10 granadas como el más pequeño
vamos a colocar la respuesta y a
comprobar la es correcta hagamos uno más
esto se pone divertido el gobierno
publicó un diagrama detalle y hoja y una
vez más tenemos pero ahora son leones el
número de leones en cada uno de los
zoológicos cuál fue el mayor número de
leones en cualquier zoológico vamos a
revisar nuestra columna de escenas y
tenemos de 10 a 19 20 30 40 50 es el
número más grande fue 50 y algo vamos a
ver cuál es ese algo recuerda que este 0
nos representa 50 no que esté vacío 50
es el número más grande vamos a colocar
50 leones como el mayor número de leones
en cualquier zoológico y es correcto
para que no perdamos la práctica el
comprador de una cadena de supermercados
creó el siguiente diagrama de tallo y
hoja que muestra el número de berenjenas
en cada una de las tiendas cuál fue el
menor número de berenjenas en cualquier
tienda de comestibles
61 59 49 47 34 32 y así podemos bajar
sobre nuestra columna de las decenas a
esta fila en la que tenemos del 10 al 19
pero nos damos cuenta que en esta fila
de las decenas tenemos cero decenas y si
tenemos unidades se dan cuenta cero
decenas más siete unidades es igual a 70
decenas más tres unidades es igual a 3
nos preguntan cuál fue el número menor
de berenjenas en cualquiera de las
tiendas tenemos cero decenas dado que es
el número más pequeño y de estas las
unidades más pequeñas son tres vamos a
colocar que en la tienda en la que menos
berenjenas había había únicamente tres
comprobemos nuestra respuesta y es
correcta y con eso hemos terminado